el duelo se esparció por todo el mundo y
las repercusiones no se detienen jefes
de estado presidentes y primeros
ministros expresaron su sentido pésame a
la familia real por la muerte de la
reina isabel segunda los presidentes de
francia y ucrania fueron uno de los
primeros en reaccionar su majestad la
reina isabel segunda encarnó la
continuidad y la unidad de la nación
británica durante más de 70 años guardó
el recuerdo de una amiga de francia una
reina de corazones que marcó para
siempre su país y su siglo tuvo consumo
con profunda tristeza me he enterado de
la muerte de su majestad la reina isabel
segunda una gran pérdida para toda
europa y el mundo por parte de todos los
ucranianos expreso mis más sinceras
condolencias a la familia real a todo el
reino unido ya toda la mancomunidad de
naciones nuestros pensamientos y
oraciones están con ustedes washington
kilitos
los primeros ministros de los países
miembros de la mancomunidad de naciones
canadá nueva zelanda australia e india
también rindieron homenaje de forma
pública su majestad la reina isabel
segunda será recordada como una
incondicional de nuestro tiempo ella
brindó un liderazgo inspirador a su
nación y a su pueblo ella personificó la
dignidad y la decencia en la vida
pública dolido por su fallecimiento mis
pensamientos están con su familia y la
gente del reino unido- en esta triste
hora la vecina irlanda con quien se
mantiene una turbulenta relación desde
hace siglos dio su sentido pésame a su
familia y pueblo en duelo el gobierno
irlandés se une a ustedes en el duelo
por la pérdida de una mujer excepcional
que lideró con un ejemplo tranquilo y
digno y que tocó tantas vidas durante su
reinado excepcionalmente largo en el
continente americano estados unidos
méjico perú brasil y venezuela también
se unieron envió mis condolencias a los
pueblos del reino unido por el
fallecimiento de la reina isabel segunda
monarca británica y soberana de 14
estados independientes de igual manera
las hago extensivas a sus familiares
amigos y miembros de la casa real fue la
primera monarca británica con la que
personas de todo el mundo pudieron
sentir una conexión personal inmediata
ya sea que la escucharon en la radio
como una joven princesa hablando con los
niños del reino unido o reunidas
alrededor de sus televisores para la
coronación mirando su último discurso de
navidad o su jubileo de platino en sus
teléfonos y ella a su vez dedicó toda su
vida al servicio de ellos la onu líderes
de la unión europea y de varias naciones
de áfrica ex colonias británicas y el
presidente de rusia vladimir putin
también guardaron luto a la reina más
longeva que ha tenido reino unido